hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Amnesia the bunker I
haven't even seen the monster yet but I
have a few objectives I've got a lot of
fuel I have a lump of meat I've got a
gun with God knows how many bullets in
it how many bullets
one
good okay well I got one bullet which is
better than no bullets I guess and then
I got this janky light I hesitate to
even call it a light so what I'm gonna
do this time and I know that you guys
are all infuriated at me and yada yada I
know we're actually going to turn this
on because there's no point in hoarding
all of it if I'm never gonna use it or
unless you guys were all like oh my God
he's doing it so good he's so smart not
using the fuel what a smart guy well too
bad for you I'm gonna use it so here we
go
chunk
how do I set this
ah damn I got an hour
well let's see if that's actually an
hour if that's an in-game hour or
something like that
but supposedly that makes the
up right in here at all oh does it like
chew up less power if I do this
ooh I don't know why I would but no it
would right unless the generator is like
constant I don't know
okay
well this bodes well kind of oh I got a
code didn't I
Belial DeLisle DeLisle I got a code from
DeLisle
all right DeLisle
oh this is absolutely not not a real
hour
point of this okay the Lyle the Lyle the
Lyle the Lyle the Lyle the Lyle the
Lyle's got a circle uh five four five
zero okay
I didn't need to get the power God I'm
wasting it aren't I so many people were
like turn on the lights and then so many
people were like oh I don't do it you're
doing so smart and good my God you look
handsome today and I was like yeah
lights are on
but the lights are on
you can't possibly
it's a lie it's a lie the door is open
over there of course it's a lie
it's 100 a lie oh it's not a lie
oh
hand
okay well that wasn't a lie but I
it's not good either I
okay
[__]
all right well I'm just wasting time
here uh are you gonna get me if I try to
do this thing with this thing
you gonna give me don't get me don't get
me dude
come on
there we go
well this is uncomfortable but whatever
this game is not about being comfortable
this game is about plowing ahead and
being competent
is what I is okay
all right whatever you have 50 minutes
um I don't know which way I was supposed
to go are we the prison Communications I
remember something about the prison
being said or the communications so I'm
gonna go to the prison because that's
what I said first
and obviously I'm always right the first
time oh God maybe there's a friend over
here
all right
lovely oh good yeah do that yeah do that
oh do that are you chasing me
oh what are you doing
oh oh
I don't know
shut up oh sh oh oh oh no
oh oh what what the frick oh my God oh
my God
shut up my dude
freak oh
uh-huh I don't know what's happening
I wish I knew what you were saying
oh no on
Twitter
oh my god
oh that's not good
oh that that's
that that's not good
why is everything locked why did I come
down here
what was the point of this
finally something
we have a poop and chair
nothing I got a stick is that what I got
I got a stick I came all this way for a
stick
block this that'll work
that'll definitely work
um okay this is so useless oh this was
such a waste of my time oh man
okay this is open
okay
okay eventually I'll get bolt cutters I
think I actually saw them in his room so
maybe that'll be a thing for me someday
so did he come through this room and
then come busting through
is that what it did
found a lot of good that's gonna do me
okay
um
sub map has been added to the map in the
administration well that's good yeah I
know I need to go to the guy in there
but
it's it just ain't happening like this
ain't happening unless I can use this
I probably can't blow up a like
reinforced door
but I bet I can blow up wooden doors
because this door is all broken
there was a wooden door in like a Supply
Closet over there
and if anything I can just use this to
oh
why why did that happen
I don't know much time I can't I can't
waste like oh my God hurry oh Jesus
okay
Adventure
yeah I know I know buddy
okay
I don't know why I closed that door but
it did
okay one bullet
yeah that did it
okay
oh that's not good that's not good
that's not good that's not good
oh my God oh my God oh my God
I have a glass
thank you
oh
okay
oh my God
oh no don't do that
don't do that
wasn't this supposed to be like a supply
closet or something
oh there's another door there boy really
would like to oh man are these all
locked up or something no they're not
I don't have a bullet for it but well
that's handy
I got a stick
um
well time to see if this works
uh throw
[Music]
well it seems to be right in that little
hole there
I mean I I hear it I think I see its
breath and I think that's a
[Music]
I think that's a pretty solid indication
that it's there and I probably shouldn't
go any closer to that hole
so uh considering that time is short I'm
gonna go
um great and I don't have uh a wrench or
anything I don't think I could take this
off no there's something here
what do we got remember if you need to
remove grading request this special
wrench from Foreman Stafford down in
maintenance while you're there ask him
why they use these damn special screws
and all the grading very inefficient
yeah it is okay good
glad that they have an in-game reason
for that oh I'm I'm leaving I'm I'm I'm
out I'm out
it's probably just waiting for the
lights to go out maybe that's why it's
not coming out maybe it doesn't like the
lights maybe it was a good idea to turn
on the lights in the first place
probably
um let's go the way we were supposed to
go wait I got a can of gas oh man I got
too much stuff in my on my person
[Music]
hold on
oh you're not in here right you're good
turn this off
hold on hold on
turn off
well that was a whole lot of useless but
I guess I did get a gas can
not that I really wanted to use that but
that did help
all right
okay uh rag stick don't know what that's
for health haven't needed to heal yet
a grenade would be useful actually to
hold on to my person
um fuel might be nice if I get caught
like if I hold on to fuel that way I I
don't get stuck without it
well I don't like that that that's
uncomfortable I still haven't actually
seen it and that makes me feel weird
alright soldiers quarters maybe I might
be able to get some guns or something
over there
did I go in all those small rooms I
don't think I went to The Wine Cellar
but I don't know why I'd need that if
this game
something about what frictional games
does they just really nail the ability
to be chased and it's not good and I
hate it and it's awful and they're great
at it and they should feel bad about
that
I'm gonna turn on the light I'm not
dealing with this I while I have fuel
I'm gonna use fuel so let's just
come on I'm so weak
please
okay can I all right it automatically
did it so that's something
all right let's go to the soldiers
quarters I don't even know what we're
going for I don't even know why but I'm
going for it
I don't even know if running is a good
idea
probably not
bro all right
come on recharge the hello
wait
wait my my inventory stuck I'm not
I can't
I can't oh God wait I can't I literally
cannot
I couldn't raise and lower my hands okay
we're back here let's just start this
again and go for it no I'm so weak
[Music]
all right
that's something about the soldiers
quarters I'm sure there was something
important down here and I'm supposed to
remember it but all I remember is that
soldiers have guns which might mean that
there might be bullets down here which
would be very useful to me
you don't need to follow me oh why is
there no lights here
oh
lights yes please thank you
oh okay daisy chain switches the power
in this part of this facility is daisy
chain shut off the power in one section
and change the subsequent areas will go
off as well switches should only be
turned off under extraordinary
circumstances like when I say so pranks
and Mischief will be reported directly
to the foreman
well not to the foreman to Raynard okay
so these both have x's on them that's
probably a sign that I shouldn't tamper
with that
all right whatever why do they gotta be
Daisy chained
why you gotta be daisy chaining
some music
well that's awful I'm not doing that
not doing it
security oh come on
oh but there's goodies in there
all right I guess I'll go into the
horrible rat room I'm assuming those are
rats
stop raining under that assumption hi
Hi how are you
yep you just enjoy yourself finally got
some answers from the engineering team
command believes there are old Roman
tunnels adjacent to our position they're
opening them this evening command hopes
to use them to launch a surprise attack
as if any attack at this point could
turn surprise this is a war we're always
expecting an attack curious to see these
tunnels though a little dash of
antiquity would liven up the place I'd
certainly help keep my mind off The
Daily Grind of war the officers
presented me with a rather unexpected
and strange gift aging texts from inside
the Roman tuttles seems like a word of
my interest I took them of course but
the truth is these techs are far too
fragile too valuable to survive life in
a horrid place they require more
delicate hands more learned Minds than
mine still curiosity Reigns this morning
Ackerman died of his wounds I'd only
known him a time but considering him one
of my better friends here I hope Heaven
welcomes him to distract myself I've
been going over the text and have not
had quite the shock these texts are not
Roman in origin the language is Latin or
Latin native at least but what they're
writing about is no relation to what I
know of Roman culture from any era the
text seemed to be of a religious or at
least superstitious nature phrase is
repeated to cross into the darkness
Beyond and then something about sight
haven't slept need to get this down the
texts are of a religious nature whoever
these ancient people were they believed
that they had found a means to
immortality to achieve this goal they
needed access to what they thought was
some other world when dominated by
darkness and ruled by I don't know they
use words I can't translate ruled by
something they claim that dark other
world was full of spirits monsters and
that the air there was endlessly alive
with the cries of tormund and the sickly
rattle of souls near death that is what
they were using the tunnels for for them
there was a doorway into some Pagan hell
the texts are full of wild stories of
blood orgies of sadistic spirits of the
awful things these men and women do to
each other in worship of Darkness they
speak at length of some substance that
is meant to Grant the worthy some kind
of immortality and darkness
I'm on patrol tonight I need to sleep
before then
but then I'm back at this
I'm right back at this you hear that
rats
you hear that ratty boys what's up there
I saw that glint in the Darkness
ah good another page we whirl the world
the world we World it all gets lost in a
terrible twirl can see the Sun for all
the smoke can't see the ground for all
the folk dead folk can't see the ocean
can't see the trees so I stay here down
on my knees singing and singing well
this is sad
that hi rats hi guys what they hurt why
what
that's a grenade
why wait wait a minute
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
close it close it close it oh my
God
oh
Daisy chained
Daisy chained oh that's off wait how did
I get back around here wait what do you
mean
what do you mean that's impossible
oh
where is it
where is this damn thing
why can't I see it
was that a thumb thump
oh
Fourier Claims One of Us killed Raynard
but I still raynard's corpse his eyes
were gone got from his skull his tongue
was shredded we all hated ranted but
none of us could have done this or as a
brutality but it is anonymous mechanized
we fire distant soldiers whoever did
this it was intimate it was sadistic
a fear for us all yeah I fear for me
[Music]
oh fuel ah Health oh I need the health
don't I I'm yeah I'm blood
okay prep the health grenade
oh yeah just drop that on the floor
man those rats um
yeah they suck
okay
got some fuel though that's nice
okay did that not turn any oh it's
darker
oh
don't do whatever you're planning
another grenade that's nice
oh I did have a grenade so technically
speaking well that's
tempting
very tempting
oh yeah
what happens if I throw a grenade in
there is that a waste of a grenade no
it's a
nine
whose is this
oh my God
[Music]
oh there's a lot of holes here oh
there's a lot of holes here what's with
this it doesn't look like an explodey
Barrel but it's got a hole in the side
oh
I feel like I should blow you up I feel
like I should blow you up I feel like I
should blow you up I feel like I should
blow you up
yay
that's definitely getting me in trouble
currently presently I am in trouble
hello please can I no I can't hide in
that oh please hide me
hard I'll take you down with me
what's up
[Music]
okay so far so good perfectly good why
is there music playing here
ah the radio of course of course
[Music]
I'm never gonna be able to get out of
here I just want to say that out loud I
have gotten myself into such a deep
Corner that I'm never going to be able
to escape but I do have revolver bullets
hearty hole
[Music]
oh my God hidey hole
okay
I think I can shoot that lock and then
hide in the hidey hole and I'll be fine
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah
God damn I'm good
oh
[Music]
God I hope my microphone isn't active
oh my God
[Music]
I got 20 minutes 20 minutes I've got 20
minutes ish to see what was beyond that
door whether it was worth it and how I'm
going to be angry at myself when it
wasn't worth it
oh my God no
[Music]
oh no thank you
is that is this helpful to me is this
what you call helpful
I can't believe it but I don't need it I
need the gas more I I do I I don't even
know if I need the gas but I feel like I
needed the officers have abandoned us
they ran from the Beast and blew the
exit you already knew this even jubert
they call this cowards and traitors and
worse if
now they've doomed us whatever hell we
suffer nowadays on them yeah but I
already know about that one
was this
um necessary I feel like this
really just boned me for some reason
why did I spend all of this effort to
come here
oh maybe to turn that on so that it
could turn on another section because
they're all Daisy chained
is that it
might be it oh yeah that's it that's
definitely it
okay
how are you alive how how stop ow Frick
stop [__]
I mean injury oh
Ah that's a good point I didn't think
about oh my God
where did that turn on it turned on
power somewhere
[Music]
did that
oh yeah that was that
but
oh [__] do I gotta do like I gotta go
back I gotta go back I just gotta go
back I'm injured I'm trailing blood and
it ain't good
oh frick oh frick huh oh hammer
I'm wasting fuel
[Music]
okay turn it off turn it off
turn it off okay yeah
well damn
that is
uh stressful now that's uh looking
pretty good
clunk
all right
frick frack
even all right so I went down one side
and I turned on a light down there I'm
assuming that somehow it's gonna turn on
something to open the door if I turn on
the other side but I I don't know why
I didn't think that these locks could be
that significant but I do need one of
these no
grenade
[Music]
okay
God damn this is stressful I really want
to emphasize that
it's very stressful
you did a good job here and man for
being soldiers where are the bullets
where are the bullets this is this is
absurd that you don't have this many
bullets I just want to say I feel like
there should be more
I don't believe
this would be this case but it is okay
I'm going back to the soldiers quarter I
was onto something I don't know what
though but I was on to something
ugh I am a soldier after all or
something all right here we go
full clock
keep this up and keep my expenditures
relatively economical let me go ahead
and put this on my no that there grenade
is three just in case
just in case
once I do that I'll be
tip top shape
oh that drop of blood sure was there
okay that's not open why is this not
open
why
oh
okay oh [__] oh God
oh my God
oh freak oh
[Music]
laughs
well that was a little close what is
that thing what plunger ass flare
can be thrown yeah well
all right
one bullet
oh why why why why why why
oh my God
well I wouldn't want to waste my one
bullet on him
I've got some pictures to look at what
oh so I was right so there is a way to
daisy chain all the switches once I get
all the switches then this door should
open and then I'll be good to get
something
okay uh
dick nice freaking stick I can't so
I know this door is here like that I
could use my grenade to open it
it wouldn't be prudent but I have it so
let's try it oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy
I didn't know that there were boxes like
that on the ground that could be open
like that
okay
that was extremely effective
somehow oh there was a gas Barrel in
here that was doubly effective then any
bullets any at all
what is this about there's no keys in
here what was even the point of getting
in here my friend after the tunnel
sabotaged her increasing security
everywhere I've been commanded to lock
the door to Communications but between
you and me I'm going to need to keep a
copy of the key in my bunk in the
barracks you never know such a thing
might come in handy
yep
yeah you just don't know yeah you just
don't know when such a thing could come
in handy who was that who even was that
who even was that Sergeant Goff
great I don't even know where golf is
in the barracks I'm assuming that's in
one of these rooms here
so there's a key
somewhere in those rooms but
frick
Frick man uh Frick okay these have names
they do goth
golf golf
oh my god there it is
you
oh God
drop it no just drop it don't don't you
dare
all right I got the communications key
you son of a [__]
oh my God okay
great
[Music]
wow that's dark
uh but at least I got a daisy chain I
think I actually did need to do that
foreign
ER is gone Insanity chaos we were in the
mess and it burst from the Shadows right
behind boys Hall the Farber was there
ready practically threw himself in front
of the thing and he shot it hit it dead
on the thing retreated we thought for
sure it was dead but then not 10 minutes
later it came back for him I heard him
screaming being pulled into the wall
praying for salvation and now I can hear
him moving again getting closer have to
move now roll suffer his fate while
Farber was ready why weren't you guys
you really let your guard down like that
is
zero
one
six
zero one one six Arsenal code I like
that Arsenal Cody
wait the Arsenal code
zero one one six I feel like that's
randomly generated I don't think he just
talks like that I wonder if this flare
would work against because there is
technically a lock thing but I'm not
gonna do that
I'm just gonna go I got the Arsenal code
I don't remember why oh for the dynamite
probably
so am I done here did I do it I think I
did it holy [__] I did it
oh my God oh my God
oh I'm out here I'm out of here I'm out
of here I'm out of here I'm out of here
I got a bunch of goodies and I'm out of
here
wait actually I got someone else's code
oh
what oh frick Lamar
clemo Clement clemo Clement why is there
no clamor
oh frick
limo where's clemo
oh frick oh frick over shouldn't have
done that why is Clemente
oh my God
oh my God I'm going around I'm going
around
oh close the door
oh my God close it lock it oh
just save it
oh
those windows were closed for business
hmm
full
all right that's nice is there some like
benefit to filling it up when it's only
a certain amount empty oh
well we finally saw it
um that was cool
warden's office oh yeah but I have the
key to the Arts of the code to the
Arsenal I like the sound of Arsenal
because that sounds like there would be
bullets in it that's what that sounds
like I never got the map in there
because I never actually managed to open
the other thing but whatever
lineageless grenades but not what I need
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna go out
this time
and I'm gonna try to just save some gas
I'm just gonna go out I know it's dark
oh actually but wait where were the
where is Clemons
did I go in all of these it's one of
these guys might have had something good
I got kind of sidetracked because I
went in
didn't Fournier go crazy after
tremblay's death bunker descended into
chaos every taken control and ordered
the men to form up in squads there to
hunt down the Beast and kill it tell me
it's not possible yeah yeah sure it's
not I'll show you I've ordered increased
security for the Arsenal lock and code
and I will root out those responsible
for this horrendous act Justice will be
done for France lock and code
lock lock and code
why has it got to be a lock and code
let me in the Arsenal then I can Lock
and Load
oh
well that's good
oh that looks fun
look at those
people
[Music]
all right well that was nothing
Brainerd that's nothing can't get in
there
I need to stop blowing up doors I have
the bad habit of wasting grenades and
not wasting things like fuel
although right now I gotta admit I'm
kind of saving
are these rats just appearing out of
nowhere because I feel like they weren't
that bad before
why why heartbeat
maybe if I'm not running everywhere
it's a little better
oh
oh I probably should have turned on the
power for this one
oh
yeah I definitely should have turned on
the power oh well I feel like in any of
these boxes there could be many many
many bullets
I like bullets
can I have bullets
why can't I get in any of these I don't
even see a way in around it am I
supposed to blow up these doors
I feel like I might be supposed to blow
up these doors
yoink
uh that joint
oh boy
oh my God
[Music]
I'm turning on the lights I'm turning on
the lights that was a terrible idea it
was a terrible idea to go without lights
I admit it I'm a fool and you know what
I won't do foolish things ever again no
I just won't do it I'm not gonna do that
um
and I got a bottle of gas I got a tank
let's just
waste that why not I don't want and I
Will Not Waste come on please all right
let's get in there
yeah that's right that's lights yeah
what do you think of Lights bud
you don't like those do you ah
nope
[Music]
oh my God it's so much better
oh my God
oh that's wonderful oh that's a thing of
beauty
all right
let's still not be stupid about this
nope that's being stupid about this
you're not out and about are you
oh dead rats
no code damn it all right
all right really this is a grenade okay
whatever
explosive storage God that sounds
amazing oh please oh
I got it
well damn no I could reach that
okay so we got an explosive Barrel there
this definitely won't be oh I know the
Arsenal code
wait wait
wait wait wait wait don't
swimming in gas
and grenades
oh whoa I bet I could blow that up
that'd be sick as hell
well this looks noisy
man there's so many just fuel fuel fuel
for days
that's extraordinarily useful oh God
I see those
trip wires
yeah this is more gas than I can carry I
better find a door to blow up or I'm not
going to be able to use all this can I
squeeze through ah not quite uh maybe I
could stack a barrel jump over no not
quite
that's too loud to run I don't want to
do that
oh
hold on bud
feel like I could I could probably blow
this up because it looks pretty weak and
wooden but I don't know where I would go
if I did oh maybe I could like tuck some
these here and then hide behind them
could I sneak I could
if I slide them in place technically
speaking I can I can hide I'll just stay
away when before it booms and I'll wait
and then it'll boom
I'm so smart
I'm so smart I'm so smart
I'm really smart guys I'm really smart
oh what are you doing
foreign
I'm very smart
a lot of time
I'm gonna leave that gas there
I'm just gonna make my way
trip line oh hi RADS God damn you rats
of [__]
oh I should blow you up
I should tip that on you actually
oh my God holy [__]
if I were to jump up on this and then
push it over on me
[Applause]
yeah
God
no it's fine
it's fine
oh no
oh
wow
oh my God
foreign
I forgot how much noise
that makes
Frick it's gonna make me push this isn't
it
there we go no
get on my way
oh frick
okay
well that's good
that's the other end of the little
alcove I was in
okay
gas in here
can't carry anymore
I don't need this
there's so many shells
so many stupid shells
oh so much fragile breakable [__] how
much time I got I'm I'm really burning
oil
oh my God oh my God
oh frick
terrible terrible terrible everything's
terrible everything's terrible thank
goodness that wasn't a grenade
it's just a flare or something
great
oh God
that's not good
oh oh my God
oh my God oh my God what do I do about
that
why what
why
foreign
[Applause]
thank you for that I think
oh okay oh man this is I really would
yeah man
I don't want to have to do
I think I could maybe stack something
and
maybe jump over hit this yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah don't have to blow anything up
don't have to attract attention watch
out for tripwires
I gotta be close to whatever the hell
I'm going for I have to be close oh God
I am close
right here right here right here
oh my God this is what I need
you know Matt I don't have any room for
the dino Matt
I treat a grenade for the dino mod I
mean I could always come back here
because this is not too far so the fuel
fuel I could do
because that means there's
oh I just wish there was freaking
bullets
anything of value
oh God why
okay so I got the dino mod
then I just need a Detonator and
basically that's all there was that
that's all it said I needed
so how do I get out of here is away from
this side
oh
assumed
oh frick
how is this not open from this side how
much time I got
oh shoot oh shoot okay well uh God damn
um
only openable from behind uh well Frick
me
um
what's in this I gotta I got there's
gotta be something good in the store let
me here
so take this
oh
I'm gonna run right out of fuel I'm
gonna run right goddamn out of fuel I'm
right out of fuel
what why did I put that away
wait did he really not come out there
oh oh I see him I see him he's coming
out
wait wait wait wait you don't see me do
you whoa
no
what have I done to you
how did you see me through the tiniest
little hole
I just saw my big beautiful eyes
hey
ah screw you so hard screw you in every
way
through all of the oh wow
oh more items in my inventory is this
gonna be like the meat so
that's
more bullets
okay so if I were to say take this meat
and Chuck it over there
now I would do anything you wouldn't do
anything
oh my God I hate that
oh my God
thank you
I'm going for it what the [__] this [__]
this [__] this [__] this oh [__] this
waiting around crap I'm not doing it
oh frick where am I going
screw this screw this screw this screw
all this screw all of this
oh you're on the wrong side Bud you're
on the wrong side Bud you're on the
wrong side Bud you're on the wrong side
Bud you're on the wrong side bud
I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out
I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out Kaboom I
think he just set off a grenade the
freaking dummy
dummy
wow that that went great that went super
good
oh my God I did it I got the Dinos
I ran out I ran down fuel a lot but man
there is so much fuel in there if I need
fuel again I just go there in the
darkness and I crawl around because
there's enough hiding spots that I can
make it but that's gonna have to wait
until the next episode thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm
loving this this is terrifying but in
just the right way it's not overly
frustrating because I don't feel always
cornered but sometimes I feel cornered
and that's beautiful it's a very nice
balance to be in so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]